Traductor: valentina caruso
Revisor: Subhashree Beeman
Buenas tardes.
Me siento como en el primer minuto
de inicio de semestre.
A pesar de los años de experiencia
la sensación de ansiedad es inevitable.
Y es que estar enfrente
de un salón de clases
o una audiencia como ustedes
siempre implica
emprender un viaje.
Pero, en cuanto al viaje de la vida
ese conocido por nuestras familias
y que nos tratan de enseñar
resulta que sus recursos
se encuentran distribuidos
en diferentes etapas, y en
distintos escenarios.
Y estos mismos van aumentando
junto a las vueltas al sol.
Entonces, parece casi evidente
la pregunta.
¿Cómo prepararnos para ese viaje?
Esta tarde quiero platicarles
de una de esas etapas
y de esos momentos
de este viaje.
La preparatoria.
Un lugar en donde no sólo debemos
de prepararnos para dar el gran salto
a la vida profesional y universitaria.
Sino que también comenzamos
a ser conscientes
de estar en un viaje.
La primera vez que entré al salón
de clases fue a las siete de la mañana.
Era verano en tierras jarochas.
Los chicos no sabían quién iba a ser
su maestro de Historia de México
y para mí iba a ser la primera vez
que yo iba a enseñar y tenía
la responsabilidad
de enseñar la historia de mi país.
Entonces, decidí vestirme de manera muy formal
pero también casual.
Algo como... intentando ser "cool".
Y bueno, decidí ponerme un saco gris
una camisa muy naranja, unos
jeans cualquiera
y unos Converse favoritos
desde la universidad.
Sí, este era yo.
Este era yo el primer día de clases.
Desde el momento en que abrí la puerta
(como ahorita) los comentarios aparecieron.
Algunos llegaban a decir:
"¿Ese es el profe?"
Otros se atrevieron a decir:
"¿Es un alumno nuevo?"
Me veía chavito.
[risas]
El problema de la materia de
Historia resulta ser
que pocos la consideran interesante.
Recuerdo que algunos seguían dormidos
(eran las siete de la mañana).
Otros más, jugaban con la silla
como si fuera una mecedora.
Emanuel, de hecho.
Pero estábamos ahí.
Todos nosotros, en este nuevo viaje.
Entonces, empezamos a revisar
nuestras maletas.
Lo que yo llamo "Maletas Culturales".
De formación universitaria
yo soy Antropólogo Social.
Siempre me interesé por los signos,
los símbolos, los sistemas de creencia
los "cómo" y los "por qué" de las personas.
Y entonces, estaba ahí.
Observando a cada uno de ellos.
Recuerdo a una chica, Jenny
que se pintaba las uñas durante mi clase
y llenaba el salón con aroma a acetona.
Siempre llegaba y le decía:
"Jenny... ¿neta? Estás en clase."
Y seguía.
Hubo otro chico, Gabo
que defendía con orgullo la identidad de
otro país, como si fuera la propia.
Llegaba y defendía esa otra bandera.
Yo era el maestro de Historia.
Era como: "¿qué pasa?"
Y le hacía preguntas sobre ese país.
Y las respondía.
En lugar de enojarme, era como:
"Viene preparado. Sabe lo que está aportando."
O la tercera chica.
Muy segura de sus conocimientos
que me entregaba los exámenes
con siete de diez preguntas.
Y me decía:
"¡Ay, profe! ¡Esas están bien!
Las demás, ni pierdo el tiempo".
Bueno.
Así estaban ellos.
Mostrando sus egos como
cualquier joven de esa edad.
Pero también eran conscientes
de estar en un salón de clases.
De seguir ciertas reglas.
Y nos lanzamos al viaje, juntos.
Yo enfrente de ellos, platicando,
conociéndolos.
Entonces comenzamos
y mi propuesta va por aquí:
Conocer y entender el equipamiento
cultural de cada grupo escolar.
Y quiero aclarar esta
pequeña analogía.
No me refiero a que como docentes
debamos hacer una revisión exhaustiva
sobre toda la maleta cultural
de cada grupo escolar.
Es... mucho tiempo.
Sino más bien, a poner atención
a elementos clave
de ese intercambio cultural.
Es así como la chica de las uñas, Jenny.
Me confesaba y decía:
"Isaac, en verdad discúlpame
por estar pintándome las uñas
en tu clase
pero yo aprendía más escuchando cómo
te apasionabas sobre la historia de México
que tomando notas.
Hubo otro chico que me dijo:
"Profe, la neta la materia me aburría
pero por el hecho de llegar
y debatir contigo, asistía."
Y eso ya es un gran logro.
Como lo verán, existen muchos elementos
que afectan al aprendizaje
pero sobretodo al motivarse
para aprender.
Es allí donde la antropología me permitió
generar nuevas dinámicas.
Pero estas dinámicas, tanto van a ayudar
para el aprendizaje significativo
(que tanto se busca en el aula)
como para generar una relación constructiva
entre el maestro y el alumno
sobre su equipamiento cultural
y con ello descubrir la utilidad
de ese saber
pero sobretodo su uso de modo personal.
Motivar a los jóvenes implica
expresar nuestros "por qué".
Nadie sigue a los grandes líderes
porque "creemos" y saben más,
o porque tienen poder.
Siempre necesitamos conocer los
"por qué" de las personas
que tratamos de seguir o replicar.
Y les digo, yo no buscaba ni busco
reclutar nuevos antropólogos
sino generar esa confianza
entre el docente y el alumno.
Al yo exponer mi maleta cultural,
ellos desde su propia toma de decisiones
pueden construir la suya.
Es así como el año pasado
me presenté con mis grupos.
Más de cuatro.
Y les propuse lo siguiente:
Presentar y armar un proyecto
ante las Naciones Unidas.
Exactamente a la UNICEF.
Los primeros chicos
me dijeron:
"Ah... sobres."
Y se fueron.
Otros más me dijeron:
"Oye... no suena mal, pero
no estoy interesado."
Algunos se atrevieron y dijeron:
"A ver, cuéntame más."
Y no comencé a decirles
todas las reglas del proyecto,
las fechas, qué había que hacer.
Sino a motivarlos a que expusieran sus ideas
en un escenario mayor al de la escuela.
Lo curioso del caso no fue que se armaron
cinco equipos de cuatro integrantes cada uno
o que leyeron los 17 objetivos del
Desarrollo Sostenible de las Naciones Unidas.
Sino que todos y cada uno de ellos
tenían ideas para cambiar al mundo.
Sin embargo, la mayoría de maestros
creía que no eran viables.
O simplemente no creían en ellos.
Los tiraban a locos.
"Estás chavito. Ideas, sueños."
Y yo era el otro loco.
Los escuchaba, y entonces me decían:
"Isaac, ¿tú crees que podemos?"
"¿Crees que podemos competir contra
toda Latinoamérica?"
Y nos lanzamos.
Nos lanzamos a una competencia
evaluada por la UNICEF
y en la cual se buscaba replicar uno
de esos objetivos del Desarrollo Sostenible
en toda Latinoamérica.
Para un maestro de historia
(y para muchos maestros)
este proyecto cumplía con los requisitos
de cualquier proyecto integrador
de final de semestre.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión
no podía ser evaluado dentro del aula.
Y como sabrán:
"Si no me dan puntos, no lo hago."
Un equipo resultó ganador:
Alex, Iliana, Diana y Emilio.
Lograron su meta: ser el único equipo mexicano
en representarnos ante las Naciones Unidas
en la sede de la CEPAL,
en Santiago de Chile.
Su idea era ayudar
a cambiar el mundo
replicando uno de esos objetivos
del Desarrollo Sostenible
Exactamente sobre el cultivo
por medio de Hidroponía.
Durante una semana estuvimos en la CEPAL
aprendiendo con otros 14 proyectos Latinoamericanos.
Y ellos en lugar de exponerlo
enfrente de la clase
lo expusieron en un escenario internacional.
¿Qué fue lo común en todos los equipos
durante este proyecto?
Lo común fue, que no solamente
sus ideas no eran escuchadas.
Sino que, sobretodo, no creían
en sus capacidades.
¿Cuál es el aprendizaje de esta experiencia
más allá de la satisfacción personal?
Ha sido el poder compartir
con cada uno de ellos
este viaje sobre este proyecto.
Y es aquí donde yo he aplicado
lo que llamo:
Se los voy a platicar brevemente.
El primero de ellos es:
"Disfrutar y generar la participación."
El segundo implica estar atentos
a siempre vivir la diversidad.
El tercero es: "Actuar Sostenible."
El cuarto es: "Activar nuestras fortalezas."
Y el quinto: "Mostrar la pasión."
Les voy a platicar sobre cada uno de ellos.
Al llegar a clase y tratar
de que se genere participación
un maestro siempre se encuentra con la dificultad
de que los jóvenes no se motivan fácilmente.
Y sobretodo, en Historia.
Tenochtitlán, la época Prehispánica
la Colonia, Benito Juárez, Porfirio Díaz,
la Revolución Mexicana.
Y entonces, un día apliqué algo.
Un Jenga.
Y esto fue gracias a que yo escuchaba
a los chicos, e íbamos aprendiendo mutuamente.
Ellos querían divertirse y yo quería que aprendieran.
¿Cómo le hago?
Y ahí estábamos, aprendiendo
Historia de México utilizando un Jenga.
Y a los pocos meses se les ocurrió la idea
de generar un Pictionary
sobre temas de mundo contemporáneo.
Y entonces había conceptos como Capitalismo
que había que dibujar. O Primer Mundo,
Segundo Mundo, Tercer Mundo.
Y así el ambiente va a cambiar. Se vuelve dinámico
gracias a esa participación y diversión
puesto que no creo que podamos
construir nuestras Maletas Culturales
en escenarios donde nuestra voz
no es escuchada.
¿Por qué? Porque el aprendizaje y la
participación real se logran en grupos.
El segundo es:
"Estar atentos a vivir la diversidad."
Más allá del cliché, o que esté "de moda"
aprender del otro
creo que debemos estar atentos
y actuar diario, aprendiendo del otro.
Pero también con el otro.
El tercero es: "Actuar Sostenible."
No podemos dejar al aula como un espacio
ajeno a la dinámica del medio ambiente del siglo XXI.
Si queremos ayudar a cambiar al mundo,
tenemos que iniciar en el aula.
¿Y qué mejor que seguir los 17 objetivos
del Desarrollo Sostenible de las Naciones Unidas?
Los cuales buscan que mejoremos
nuestra situación del presente
sin comprometer los recursos
de las futuras generaciones.
Al cuarto gran canal, yo lo llamo:
"Activar nuestras fortalezas."
Es indiscutible.
Todos tenemos capacidades diferentes
pero pocos nos atrevemos
a luchar con ellas
y al momento de aprender,
nos ponemos incómodos.
¿Cuál es el más común?
Hablar en público.
Tengo muchas experiencias de chicos
a los que les da pavor pasar a exponer
enfrente de sus compañeros.
Activar nuestras fortalezas implica
los tres canales anteriores.
Es decir, saber los partícipes, vivir la diversidad
y sobretodo, tener conciencia del medio ambiente.
Yo les pregunto ahora:
¿Ustedes recuerdan aquel docente
que los invitó a continuar sus estudios?
¿A conocer un nuevo libro?
¿O a mantenerse en esos estudios
bajo la orden de "Hazlo, porque si no, te repruebo"?
Creo que la mayoría recordamos
a esos docentes que nos inspiraron
y nos motivaron en alguna parte de este viaje
como docentes apasionados.
Y es la pasión una de esas fortalezas
que hay que buscar activar en el salón de clase.
Pero ¿Cómo se va a lograr
si el docente no está apasionado?
Es así que les muestro mi pasión.
Una de ellas es la poesía.
Y otra más, escribir.
Los que me conocen en clases,
lo recordarán.
Comienzo mis sesiones de izquierda a derecha,
rayando el pizarrón. Utilizando todos los plumones
o todas las paredes.
Hasta culminar después de dos horas, con los gritos:
"¡Profe, ya se le pasó la hora!"
Y yo sudado y apurado, digo:
"Bueno, espero que hayan copiado."
Y al final quedan cosas como esta.
Entrar a una sesión de clases
es reírse y decir:
"Cuidado con los mapas mentales
de Isaac."
Yo no creo que el aprendizaje del siglo XXI
venga ajeno a no mostrar esa pasión.
Al final de los semestres he procurado
hacer explícita esta pasión
a cada uno de mis alumnos.
¿Qué he hecho?
He seleccionado una canción
muy común para los jarochos
"Veracruz" de Agustín Lara.
Se la imprimo (en tamaño mediano)
y les escribo a cada uno de ellos
sobre sus prendas culturales, con las cuales
iniciaron, desarrollaron
y terminaron el semestre.
A cada uno de ellos les entregué
estas cartas.
Tenían cosas diferentes, y pasé alrededor de tres
días haciéndolas (porque eran como 150 alumnos).
Pero sobretodo, les regalé un pambazo
junto con cada una de estas cartas.
Y algunos se acuerdan más
de los pambazos, que de las cartas.
(Ahí me ayudó mi mamá, la verdad yo no
sabía hacer pambazos)
Les dejo esta invitación:
¿Cuál es su Maleta Cultural?
Construir nuestras Maletas Culturales
implica conocer nuestras prendas,
esas prendas culturales
con las cuales viajamos.
Pero esas mismas tienen que ser
adquiridas con pasión.
Muchas gracias.
Subtítulos:
Naomi Buda Alarcón.
TEDxZamoraPark 2017